zurück bei bild live an diesem dienstag
in der woche in der deutschland die
kanzler auswechselt und wir haben hier
während wir dieser veranstaltung
gelauscht und zugeschaut haben mit olaf
scholz robert habeck und christian
lindner besuch bekommen bei uns im
studio nicht nur von bildpolitik stefan
schäfer sondern auch von wolfgang
kubicki herzlich willkommen bei uns das
war entschuldigung haben ein bisschen
schnarch veranstaltung gesagt in zeiten
des aufbruchs und so weiter erwartet man
ein bisschen was anderes als vielleicht
olaf scholz schwarze krawatte und doch
ein relativ neuer sound da ich habe mich
während der veranstaltung bisschen
gefragt wie kann das sein dass die neue
aufbruchs regierung vor dem ersten
regierungs tag müde aussieht als die
kanzlerin vor ihrem letzten
regierungstagen die pressekonferenz
nicht gesehen weil ich auf dem weg
hierher war auch ein bisschen mehr drive
reinzubringen die veranstaltung im ernst
ist es ja so wir haben wirklich sehr
anstrengende wochen hinter uns und man
merkt heute ist ein abschluss gewesen
ein erster abschluss mitunter zeichen
der koalitionsvereinbarungen und dann
sagt natürlich auch eine ganze menge weg
das muss man einfach menschlich
nachvollziehbar aber sie treten mühte
tatsächlich an sie fangen an zu regieren
und sind schon müde nein die das
kabinett wird er morgen sozusagen erst
die arbeit aufnehmen müssen die werden
heute nacht mal richtig schön aus
schlagen und dann kann man sich drauf
verlassen nicht deutschland wird nicht
so schnell sich regiert werden wie es in
der vergangenheit der fall gewesen ist
es war jetzt heute die zweite
veranstaltung die wir hier live verfolgt
haben wir heute morgen konnten wir sehen
wie der koalitionsvertrag unterzeichnet
wurde auch da im futur ii um haben wir
so ein bisschen spaß ist aber gesagt
früher war irgendwie mehr lametta auch
das wirkt das ein bisschen getragen wird
das auf sie gewirkt es sei ein großer
historischer moment in kann man doch
eigentlich ja aber die ja die
ergriffenheit live.de
die ergriffenheit bei uns ein war ja
schon vorhanden nachdem klar war dass
die partei mit einer extrem großen
mehrheit zugestimmt haben also ich kann
mich an kein ergebnis erinnern bei dem
jedes bei der freien demokraten deutlich
über 90 prozent lagen bei der spd fast
100 prozent bei den grünen auch und dann
weiß man es hat jetzt funktioniert und
der rest ist sowieso ein symbolhafter
akt ist war deshalb nicht ganz zu
ergreifen weil der ganze saal vollmer
mit journalisten nicht als sohn eines
schnitte aber
wir waren etwas etwas gedrängt sozusagen
durch die vielen journalisten anwesend
waren und dabei sein wollten insofern
warten wir es doch einfach mal ab ich
bin froh dass wir jetzt den das stadium
erreicht haben abzulösen neu zu
installieren das wird morgen der fall
sein und dann geht es vorwärts
tatsächlich unsere kanzler reporterin
angelika hellemann die heute morgen auch
im futur ii mit dabei war hat berichtet
dass toni hofreiter einfach nur
hingegangen ist unterschrieben hat und
direkt danach den saal verlassen hat der
ist immer noch frustriert darüber dass
er nicht minister geworden ist ja ich
kann das nachvollziehen ich habe ja eine
auf fahndungsgruppe mit ihm gemeinsam
noch den mobilitäts teil mit verhandelt
es war eigentlich ein beteiligten klar
dass der verkehrsminister wird deshalb
haben wir auch so verhandelt das müssen
die grünen aber entscheidend es geht
hier der grundsatz dass die ministerien
die den jeweiligen parteien zugeordnet
werden dann auch von ihnen selbst
gesetzt werden was bei den grünen sie
abgespielt hat weiß ich nicht aber noch
einmal das ist jetzt ein neuanfang dem
wohnt ein gewisser zauber inne und ich
glaube dass daraus auch was gutes werden
können aber selbst er ihnen leid der
anton hofreiter etwas muss man sagen wir
haben ja mittlerweile auch ein
vernünftiges fenster gefunden ich weiß
dass er sehr viel von gutem essen
versteht dass er auch gute weine zu
schätzen weiß und dass er auch ein
mensch ist der immer versucht einen
kompromiss zu finden selbst wenn man
aufeinander treibt also erst mir
menschlich näher gekommen und deshalb
finde ich ein bisschen traurig dass
seine seine vorstellung sich nicht
erfüllt haben sie da einen lieblings
grünen jetzt ich hatte immer schon eine
lieblings ich habe mehrere lieblings
grüne
interessanterweise alle weiblichen
geschlechts ist steffi lemke das ist die
kann ja kann ich nicht mehr schaden
durch diese aussage das ist claudia roth
die seit über 50 jahren kenne und das
ist britta widmann die neue
fraktionsvorsitzende wird die wirklich
eine sehr gute kluge parlamentariern ist
jetzt hört man ja immer mehr dass es
streitigkeiten gab es jetzt einen streit
schon bei den grünen schon angesprochen
aber auch innerhalb der koalition lief
natürlich nicht alles immer nur harmonie
mäßig in den vergangenen wochen jetzt
sagte robert habeck da sein auch mal die
türen geknallt in den
koalitionsgesprächen wer hat die tür
geknallt sie nein aber ich glaube dass
das auch mehr wirklich gemeint hat weil
ich nicht erlebt aber das jemals türen
geknallt worden sind aber
selbstverständlich wenn man aus
unterschiedlichen positionen kommt und
kompromisse finden wie kann es auch mal
deftig werden gerade mein freund robert
habeck mit dem ich schon 2017 den
kommissionsvorschlag geführt haben ikt
gelegentlich dazu zu glauben dass das
was er denkt das maß aller dinge sei das
haben wir alle genervt oder wie er hat
also nicht die nerven und zwar haben als
am anfang wahrscheinlich ein bisschen
genervt aber es ist ja kolportiert
worden es gab einige auch in den
verhandlungsgruppen die anderen versucht
haben zu erklären wie die welt so
funktioniert und das ist natürlich bei
menschen gestanden alters dann schon
jetzt schon wissen schon also junge die
den alten versucht er zu erklären oder
leute die der grundsatz besteht heute
darin wir müssen nicht versuchen uns
wechselseitig zu überzeugen sondern wir
müssen mal gucken wie wir mit dem was in
unterschiedlichen vorstellungen haben
zueinander kommen können und der versuch
mir oder auch von uns der versuch
gelegen die andere davon zu überzeugen
dass das was wir glauben das einzig
richtige ist das kann am anfang nerven
aber das hat war war relativ zügig
vorbei also das waren daher sehr
professionell sehr konzentriert in der
sache und deshalb ist auch im
koalitionsvertrag zustande gekommen mit
dem wir alle nicht nur gut leben können
sie dann wirklich eine gute grundlage
sein wird für die nächsten vier jahre
und darauf können alle beteiligten sag
ich mal stolz sein wie funktioniert das
vielleicht können sie das noch einmal
erklären herr kubicki weil sie ja schon
sehr lange in der politik sind da
beschimpft man sich und bekämpft sich im
parlament über vier jahre vielleicht
sogar über acht jahre die fdp und die
grünen extrem hart gegeneinander das war
auch der erklärte lieblingsgegner und
plötzlich sitzt man zusammen am
kabinettstisch und
spielt so ein bisschen friede freude
eierkuchen ist das dann alles show was
wiedersehen oder ist das wirklich
ernsthaft dass man zusammen gefunden hat
und sagt okay also plötzlich passen wir
doch zusammen wenn das alles so wäre
dann würde politik ihre funktion
verfehlen denn wir haben alle unsere
überzeugung für die wir eintreten und
kämpfen wir wissen aber auch dass man
pragmatisch an problemlösungen daran
gehen muss es nützt uns ja nicht sagen
wo wir stehen und jetzt die nächsten
vier jahre in der ampelkoalition
bekriegen würden dann würde nichts
wirklich funktionieren
schlechte beispiel hatten wir schon aus
der großen koalition
es macht sinn den versuch zu unternehmen
jetzt tatsächlich diesen fortschritts
pakt mit leben zu erfüllen und den
aufbruch wirklich zu wagen selbst wenn
das war ein bisschen müde aus gesehen
hat ich bin mir sicher dass alle
beteiligten dass er die dokumentieren
werden auch als personen dass sie an dem
gemeinsamen konzept arbeiten und noch
einmal lassen wir die leute erstmal
anfangen ergeben wir ihn tatsächlich ein
bisschen zeit sich auch in den
ministerien zu organisieren und ich bin
sicher und das sage ich jetzt nicht
einfach so dahin ich habe heute morgen
mit karl lauterbach beispielsweise noch
mal gesprochen ich bin sicher dass aus
den mahner kein autobauer auch ein
macher wäre kann das daran wird er
gemessen werden und diese zeit sollten
wir allen beteiligten geben über denen
man wollen wir nämlich jetzt auch ganz
in detailliert sprechen wir sagen sie
haben heute morgen mit ihm telefoniert
wir wollen einmal reinschauen sie sagten
einmal mit paul ronzheimer zusammen und
da war karl lauterbach muss man sagen
sie haben sie vielleicht nicht unbedingt
geäußert dass ihr großer fan sind wir
schon einmal in die winter wir rein
in die leute hier in der stammkneipe auf
karl lauterbach bei ihnen nicht nicht
positiv versagen die sonst
also man würde den morgen so sagen die
spacken oder dracula
gesagt das sagen sie ja nicht nur hier
sondern das weiß kann auch also auch die
malocher aus dem aus leverkusen und
bochum da wo er kandidiert und da sind
wir ihnen mal schnell ins wort gefallen
aber das wichtige war das ist ja
gefallen werden liebevolle bezeichnung
für karl lauterbach morgen haben sie mit
ihnen telefoniert
ich glaube ist gesehen heute morgen
schon gestern schon gratuliert er dafür
bedanken wir uns heute morgen gesehen
uns ausgetauscht ich muss vielleicht mal
sagen weil das immer falsch popovic
packen ist plattdeutsch und heißt so was
wie jemand der einem auf die nerven geht
das ist gar nicht böse gemeint sein
leute die einem auf die nerven gehen und
dazu gehörte karl lauterbach bei mir
jedenfalls sind bei move fällt als der
ständige maler man schalte den fernseher
ein und der erste der erklärte dass wir
an der pandemie zu grunde gehen war karl
lauterbach das nervt ein bisschen und
jetzt wie gesagt das habe ich ihm heute
morgen gesagt jetzt wird daran gemessen
werden aber aus den vielen studien je
gelesen hat jetzt auch praktische
politik folgt und wir die pandemie
wirklich in den griff bekommen ohne dass
wir den leuten dauernd angst machen und
da haben wir ich traue ihm das zu aber
es ist ambitioniert aber das ist ja
eigentlich schon treppenwitz der
geschichte sie waren ja sozusagen die
lieblingsgegner in der korona krise wir
sind hier fast in keinem bild ort da
ohne sie beiden auszukommen aus gekommen
weil sie eigentlich die maximalen
gegenpole war und jetzt regieren sie
sozusagen gemeinsam machen gemeinsame
sache in dieser ampel koalition können
sie das selber begreifen und vor allen
dingen das wird richtig schwer machen
das weiß ich gar nicht weil wir beide
wechselseitig uns attestierte er
versteht mehr vom mediziner als ich und
ich verstehe mehr von just als er und
das hat ja sozusagen unseren und sagen
streit auch regelmäßig hier befeuert
wird glaube ich in dem ministerium sich
anders verhalten müssen als gegenwärtig
in talkshows weil der liebling der
nation wir haben das von jens spahn auch
schon mal gesehen dezember letzten
jahres der liebling der nation der mann
der am beliebtesten war in deutschland
sich überlegt hat ob er nicht vielleicht
kanzlerkandidat der union wird und dann
kam ein dramatischer absturz das wünsche
ich kann aber nicht im gegenteil ich
wünsche uns insgesamt dass er möglichst
schnell aus dieser situation
herauskommen aus dem doktor das nervt
ermittler weil alle beteiligten und
deshalb werden wir alles dafür tun ihn
auch zu einer erfolgreichen
gesundheitsminister zu machen weil es
für uns gut ist und wer das im karl
lauterbach ist von mir aus aber wenn sie
sagen kanada macht versteht mehr von
medizin und sie mehr von juristerei in
den letzten wochen ging es immer noch
hoch her zwischen ihnen beiden das heißt
dieser streit ist jetzt beigelegt
wolfgang kubicki wird sich an karl
lauterbach nicht mehr abarbeiten nein
also der inhaltliche streit der bleibt
also im schreiben positiven sinn wir
werden selbstverständlich auch unsere
wechselseitig unterschiedliche position
nach wie vor markieren aber nicht mit im
hinblick darauf den anderen jetzt aus
dem feld zu räumen sondern daraus dass
gemeinsam produktives zu bauen ist ja
der sinn dieser koalition wir kommen aus
völlig unterschiedlichen
vorstellungswelten und versuchen daraus
was gemeinsam vernünftiges zu machen
daran werden wir gemessen werden niemand
wird erfolgreich sein auf kosten der
anderen werde nur gemeinsam erfolgreich
hand aufs herz wer hat das härtere amt
karl lauterbach oder christian lindner
ich habe es leider ein sehr
ambitioniertes amerika lauterbach wie
gesagt werde daran gemessen wird ob aus
dem maler kann man jetzt ja macher wird
der das tatsächlich umsetzt was er immer
wieder gefordert hat ich fand die
ankündigung dass das gesundheitssystem
jetzt einen stabilisieren und aufgebaut
wird schon sehr ambitioniert weil es ja
auch mal mit kosten verbunden ist und
christian hinten aber nach dokumentieren
muss definitiv dass die überlegung der
freien demokraten wir können das alles
wuppen ohne dass wir steuererhöhungen
machen müssen und ohne dass die
schuldenbremse angefasst werden muss
dass das wirklichkeit werden kann daran
werden wir als freie demokraten gemessen
also für uns ist die funktion und
christian lindner bedeutender für die
republik die nächsten wochen und monate
die funktion von karl lauterbach wichtig
auch als würde auch in gerade in der
pressekonferenz wieder angesprochen ein
thema das ganz deutschland bewegt die
impfpflicht für viele fühlen dass es so
ist es tage wochen monate lang fast
jahrelang versprochen wurde das kommt
nicht bei uns es wird nicht kommen und
gerade die fdp hat sich daher ganz klar
positioniert wenn es eben gerade auch
wieder gehört von christian lindner der
sagte die einführung in pflicht ist kein
vorhaben der ampel koalition
gleichzeitig musste er aber auch ein
bisschen vorsichtiger in formulierung
denn werden da alle unsicher in die
zukunft weg nur das jetzt eben doch
diskutiert wird hier stehen sie das ja
gut dass die impfpflicht diskutiert wird
ist in ordnung dass wir über maßnahmen
diskutieren müssen das in ordnung in
meiner partei gibt es eine sehr
intensive diskussion über die vor und
nachteile einer impfpflicht ich selbst
das wissen alle beteiligten ich bin
gegen eine generelle pflicht daraus muss
man sich nicht erklären das entspricht
nicht meinem menschenbild was ich habe
und vor allen dingen könnte ich mich in
gedanken anfreunden wenn die impfpflicht
noch aus der pandemie heraus führen
würde ich halte das für eine freche
behauptung denn wir wissen mittlerweile
dass auch die menschen die gebucht sind
wieder infiziert werden können und
andere infizieren können und dass die
uns der prozess längerer zeit begleiten
wird ich bin für mehr aufklärung der
kampagnen ich glaube dass viele menschen
die sich momentan nicht impfen lassen
diesen schritt dann wagen wenn wir einen
impfstoff haben der jetzt nichts
zugelassen werden wird ich kriege jeden
tag würden hunderte von mails von mir
geschrieben wir der kubicki ich lass
mich sofort impfen so wie dieser
impfstoff vermerkt ist also in einer
freien gesellschaft wie unserer bin ich
mehr für überzeugung als für diese vier
jahren ging es weise aber ich kann
menschen auch verstehen die glauben
nicht wenn wir alle durch die ems sind
dann haben das problem im griff und dann
machen wir das wie gesagt mit meinem
rechtsverständnis eine anstellung zu
wollen mit meinem menschenbild schon gar
nicht wir diskutieren momentan eine
sektorale impfpflicht oder flaschen
alters begrenzt die impfpflicht ethikrat
wird das wahrscheinlich vorschlagen
menschen ab 60 sollten sich alle impfen
dass eine pflicht in der pflicht da kann
man wirklich nachdenken noch einmal ich
bin insgesamt sehr skeptisch wenn man
jetzt gegen die impfpflicht ist und
bleibt findet man dann in der fdp sein
natürliches zu hause oder hat man in
deutschland extreme positionen damit ein
in der freien demokraten finden sie auf
jeden fall zu hause weil wir das sehr
offen und ohne diskriminierung des
jeweils anderen
diskutieren es gibt ja für beides gute
argumente und die überlegung nicht man
ist ein besserer mensch für die eine
oder andere seite entscheidet die ist
nach freien demokratischen partei nicht
sehr weit verbreitet wird das nicht
gehen dass berlin als rational es gibt
nicht bessere menschen in der einen oder
anderen richtung
ich finde es schön wenn leute sagen sie
haben dazugelernt
ich habe auch dazu gelernt aber es hat
meine position nicht verändert und
insofern ich finde ich dass wir in
deutschland wären wir viel offener
miteinander reden würden ohne die
anderen jeweils moralischen den senkel
zu stellen viel weiter kommen würden als
wir das gegenwärtig tun waren wir doch
eine prognose herr kubicki wenn es zur
abstimmung kommt über die allgemeine
impfpflicht kristalls grad auch noch mal
gesagt das wird gruppenanträge geben das
heißt es wird dann ja auch
fraktionsübergreifend frei abgestimmt
werden ihre einschätzung einfach nur
eine prognose kurz vor weihnachten 20 21
wird der bundestag mehrheitlich für eine
allgemeine impfpflicht demnach sollen
sie das von vielen kollegen die sagen
nein wir sind doch dagegen das wird
keine mehrheit geben der bundestag wird
mit mehrheit dafür stimmen weil ich weiß
dass aus den reihen der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion sehr viele kollegen
kollegen dafür stimmen würden weil die
sozialdemokraten und grünen ist auch so
manier freien demokraten würde ich das
ungefähr schätzen zwischen 30 40 prozent
die gegen eine allgemeine impfpflicht
sind der rest würde dafür stimmen wie
gesagt auch mit guten argumenten er sie
wäre eine beachtliche minderheit im
deutschen bundestag außerhalb der afg
mit denen wollen wir es gar nicht reden
die trotzdem eine allgemeine impfpflicht
nicht zustimmen würden aber ist wird an
dem er dem deutschen bundestag sie gehen
davon aus dass wurde eine mehrheit geben
ja ich kann das bedauern habe ich kann
es nicht ändern jetzt ist morgen kein
ganz unerheblicher tag scholz kommt und
merkel geht nach so vielen jahren
wirklich ein historischer tag mit
zeitenwende machtwechsel hier in
deutschland sie haben jetzt noch so
zweieinhalb minuten zeit hier bei uns um
nochmal alles über angela merkel zu
erzählen über ihre persönliche
politische beziehung ihr verhältnis was
deutschland noch nicht wusste also über
angela merkel in zweieinhalb minuten zu
reden ist ja ist sehr vermessen aber ich
kann nur noch mal wiederholen dass ich
angela merkel in den verhandlungen 2017
kennengelernt habe sei eine sehr
charmante kluge gastgeberinnen mit einem
unglaublich britischen humor ihn
verstehen nicht alle sofort für
norddeutschland ist das relativ einfach
aber sie ist eine wirklich
beeindruckende persönlichkeit
beeindruckende frau und sicherheit nicht
alles falsch gemacht den letzten 16
jahren das muss man wirklich sagen ich
glaube wir hätten ohne sie und der stein
wird die finanzkrise 2009 nicht so
anständig belebt aber was wird dann
jetzt olaf scholz anders machen als
angela merkel vom auftritt her
wahrscheinlich wenig das haben sie ja
schon gesehen die wir beide sehr
zurückhaltend in ihrem auftritt
aber er wird andere akzente setzen
selbstverständlich er sozialdemokrat mit
ganzem herzen und das wird sich schon
als abzeichen in regierungspolitik so
bringen wir dann in die zukunft was
glauben sie wo wird es auch mal
reibungspunkte geben auch wenn ich gerne
optimistisch abschließen möchte aber ich
möchte mich doch auch darauf vorbereiten
wo sind punkte wie sie jetzt schon sagen
und da müssen wir jetzt in zukunft das
wird uns beschäftigen und da sind wir
uns vielleicht nicht einig ja ich hoffe
dass es jeden tag reibungspunkte geben
wird weil das können wir wenn ich
erzeugen selbstverständlich wird auch im
regierungslager immer wieder die frage
auf don dient das der weiterentwicklung
unseres landes ja oder nein ist wird
diskussionen geben bei der mobilität bei
der frage welche autobahn bauen wir noch
ja oder nein
ich bin ja ein vehementer verfechter der
a20 und die wird auch gebaut werden kann
ich schon sagen aber trotzdem ist wird
immer noch jeden tag die frage im raum
stehen ist das jetzt prioritär was wir
machen oder können wir das zurückstellen
denn wie gesagt auch unsere finanzen
wachsen nicht unter linien himmel
irgendwann muss bezahlen auch das werden
wir beide seien oder wie alle sein das
wird die deutsche bevölkerung seien
derzeit die wirtschaft und die menschen
die hart arbeiten